[Musique]
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur france 3 bourgogne et sur la
page facebook de france 3 pour ce rendez
vous spécial législatives
nous nous intéressons aujourd'hui à
lanières real yonne en partenariat avec
l'yonne républicaine et nous ouvrons
tout de suite le premier débat avec la
deuxième circonscription de la nièvre le
morvan le sud l'est du département avec
encore peut-être sur ses terres le
souvenir de françois mitterrand presse
candidate présentée par mieux nos
invités christian paul pour jour bonjour
député socialiste sortant de la
circonscription
ani le grain bonjour je vous êtes la
candidate des républicains ou investie
par votre parti harold blanot bonjour
vous êtes le candidat du front national
dans cette circonscription
patrice perron bonjour bonjour vous
porter les couleurs de la république en
marche le parti des manuels macron
tchadienne cardo vous étiez porte parole
de françois fillon pour la société
civile mais vous n'avez pas eu
l'investiture et l'air bonjour bonjour à
tous et marianne guînes à vous porter
les couleurs la france a soumis ce bon
jour où jouent tous les électeurs ne
vous connaissent pas encore forcément
tous et toutes nous vous proposons donc
de vous présenter vous dire aussi
quelles sont vos motivations
va falloir être con si vous disposez 30
secondes chacun nous avons tiré au sort
l'ordre de passage et c'est vous à rob
blake no qui commençait à bonjour je
m'appelle harold de blanot j'ai 30 ans
je suis acheteur forestier et
sylviculteurs à moux en morvan berceau
familial
je suis papa d'une petite fille je suis
diplômé de master en stratégie
d'intelligence économique
j'ai fait des études en économie en
marketing pour toi dijon même en
slovaquie et je suis engagé au front
national dont depuis mes 18 ans c'est à
dire en 2005 et je souhaite renouveler
la politique nivernaise merci patrice
perron je suis patrice perron 53 ans
marié six enfants responsable d'une
entreprise de transports sanitaires dans
la nièvre et je suis en marche depuis un
an
merci fabienne carlo bonjour je suis
élue adjointe à corbigny et cadre
dirigeant dans l'industrie lourde
récemment engagé mais très engagé dans
la vie publique locale
je reste fidèle à ma ligne
c'est à dire une fin de la société
civile de droite et j'ai demandé et
obtenu l'investiture d'un mouvement
reconnu par les républicains les
indépendants la droite et du centre pour
des acteurs économiques qui s'engage
pour la première fois pour la
législative pour le renouveau des
territoires notamment ruraux
merci christian paul bonjour bonjour
christian paul je suis député de la
nièvre de cette 2e circonscription on me
décrit généralement comme un homme de
terrain
honnête fidèle à ses convictions très
engagé pour le développement de notre
département est aussi apporteur d'idées
nouvelles et je fais équipe avec
stéphane bénédicte y est conseil
municipal de varennes vauzelles qui est
un homme engagé lui aussi dans le
mouvement sportif dans dans sa cité bien
sûr et dans la vie associative
merci jean paul a mis le brain donc je
suis nivernaise ni la nes dessous j'y
suis né j'y habite
j'ai travaillé pendant trente quatre ans
en tant que collaboratrice conjointe en
assurance je me suis engagé au sein du
conseil municipal de prémery pendant
trois mandats dont deux en tant
qu'adjointe et j'ai toujours été
investis dans diverses associations
je pense que c'est pour ça que les
républicains m'ont donné cette
investiture quand je connais bien les
nivernais et la nièvre et je suis là
pour porter le projet de la droite et du
centre pour la nièvre et pour la france
merci bonjour j'ai 46 ans je suis
céramiste je suis aussi juriste de
formation et surtout ma personne importe
peu ce qui compte c'est ce que j en
commun avec la majorité des français qui
en ont assez aujourd'hui de devoir subir
les mêmes recettes même lift et même un
joli qu'on nous sert depuis des dizaines
d'années et qui veulent aujourd'hui un
avenir en commun qui tiennent compte des
urgences sociales des urgences
écologiques et d urgence démocratique et
c'est pour ça que je défends le
programme l'avenir en commun merci à
tous les six merci pour votre concision
pour cette introduction rentrons
maintenant dans le coeur du débat avec
d'abord un chapitre très
politique on l'a voulu comme ça parce
qu'il ya une situation nationale
politique inédite qui justifie de vous
demander finalement où vous vous situez
dans ce nouvel échiquier qui s'est
redessiné après les présidentielles
majorité-opposition soutien gouvernement
refus des premières mesures annoncées
je commence par vous christian paul vous
avez été pour le grand public le leader
des frondeurs à l'assemblée nationale un
des leaders des frondeurs soucier les
journalistes oui ils le disent oui
reprenons pour nous là dessus vous vous
situez où dans cette campagne comme
certains socialistes avec le président
de la république derrière lui ou pas ou
dans une opposition dans un esprit
constructif son sectarisme
parce que la france est un pays meurtri
meurtrie par le fonds 6 terroristes qui
continuent meurtri aussi par le chômage
de masse qui n'a pas baissé donc dans un
esprit constructif mais évidemment sans
chèque en blanc
je crois qu'aujourd'hui les français ont
besoin d'être défendue ils ont besoin de
deux sentinelles très vigilante sur la
justice sociale
on va parler dans les prochains mois en
france et puis aussi dans le débat
public à l'assemblée nationale on va
parler des retraites on va parler des
salaires
on va parler du désordre donnant les
ordonnances ce qui est une façon de
remettre à plat le code du travail sans
passer par le parlement
et ceux qui aujourd'hui sont candidats
c'est un tournant et formés le code du
travail sans heurt de nom ce sont quand
même dans une candidature de soumission
à tout donc donc je terminais la tamise
je crois qu'il est très important encore
une fois d'être capable de comprendre qu
attend le pays voyez si la première loi
que propose le gouvernement est une loi
de moralisation de la vie publique après
les affaires cahuzac
fillon ferrand aujourd'hui je voterai
cette loi s'il s'agit de réformer dans
la chaleur de l'été le code du travail
a-rod non c'est à dire sans le parlement
évidemment je marquerai un total
désaccord et et je donne à part la
patrie espérons que nous serons en total
désaccord je masquer complètement dans
le projet de la moralisation de la vie
non sur le code du travail je parle
puisque aujourd'hui on a le constat de
ces quarante dernières années qu'ils ont
poussé dans des impasses aujourd'hui je
reste persuadé qu'en libérant le travail
demain le chômage naturellement se
résoudre concernant la moralisation et
la d'évidence que ma venue en marche et
d'une est une des principales
motivations que j'en étais du fait
effectivement de toutes ces affaires
successives qui ont créé un réel rejet
dans l'esprit de la population de la
politique en général donc bien
évidemment que je soutiendrai l'action
présidentielle dans sa globalité
opposition mélangeant bien vous vous
doutez que pour notre part à la france a
soumises nous n'entendons pas soutenir
la politique de monsieur macro et nous
avons pour objectif d'être majoritaires
à l'assemblée nationale il y à 7
millions de français qui ont voté pour
jean luc mélenchon au premier tour de la
présidentielle
nous sommes 500 millions soumis
aujourd'hui dans le pays
nous progressons sans cesse les gens qui
lisent ce programme sont convaincus je
conseille à tous les téléspectateurs de
retrouver ces trois euros c'est pas très
cher
il est en ligne aussi évidemment nous
lutterons contre la destruction du code
du travail qui est organisée
actuellement par le gouvernement est un
accro mais qui a déjà commencé avec la
loi comrie et avec les gouvernements
précédents
nous pensons comptanoo fut peut-être le
code du travail est un petit peu épais
mais si on commence par enlever toutes
les dérogations qui ont été obtenus par
le le medef et ses prédécesseurs il y
aura effectivement un petit peu de
clarification voilà fabien de cardo nous
sommes clairement dans une opposition
constructive au président de la
république est d'ailleurs jean
christophe fromantin fondateur du
mouvement des indépendants la droite et
du centre en a parlé avec emmanuel
macron la france du président de la
république telle que nous la voyons
aujourd'hui mais il faut qu'il précise
sans projet est plutôt la france des
grandes métropoles et les grandes
entreprises du cac 40 que je connais
bien
donc elle conduit la france vers une
mondialisation et une certaine fierté
française mais ce
nous craignons en tant que représentant
de la droite et du centre c'est coton
des valeurs de travail de liberté de
responsabilité qui sont très importantes
pour nous une certaine françois oublié
et c'est ma france c'est la france de la
seconde circonscription donc à
l'assemblée nationale moi je voterai des
amendements j'aiderai allait présenter
gelé voterai pour que l'étoile rite war
ruraux pour que les petites villes ne
soient pas oubliés et pour que la
solidarité nationale permettent le
développement a bien sûr parlé de
spécificités de votre boîtier
reconstruction forcément grasse donne la
parole à leur opposition constructive
d'un côté vous aussi opposition
constructive bien sûr avec hull une
grande probablement problématique la
ruralité qui a été oubliée depuis de
nombreuses années autant par les
gouvernements d'ailleurs de droite que
de gauche et ce sera l un de mes grands
projets pour cette campagne comment vous
réagissez à certains ni un premier
ministre de droite
aujourd'hui louis qui est membre qui
était membre du même parti que vous donc
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire quand
même que vous pourriez avoir une
certaine proximité à certains moments où
fait partie de la branche des
républicains qui clairement ne suivent
pas ça mais écoutez je me pose la
question à savoir comment il peut
défendre des projets pour lequel il
était contre auparavant
donc nous suivrons notre programme de la
droite et du centre
s'il correspond avec ses dunes premier
ministre problème si ça corresponde pas
nous les suivrons ton art 3 g qui je le
rappelle a largement évolué bien loin de
celui qui a été porté par monsieur
fillon et qui est aussi aujourd'hui bien
loin de celui qui a été porté par un
compagne présidentielle de monsieur
sommes aujourd'hui je pense que la faire
un un gouvernement très ouvert et la
ruralité est largement représentés au
travers alors on a bien la preuve ici
que le front national c'est la seule
vraie opposition au gouvernement de
macron ça fait des années
je comprends que la france a soumis ce
n'était un petit peu quand même c'est
vrai que messi il faut rester dans
l'opposition cessons de faire
zahn et qu'on dénonce le système ump ps
ump s apprêtait à l'air ps maintenant
nous avons lrm c'est pareil nous avons
bruno le maire qui part rejoindre la
majorité présidentielle
voilà c'est n'importe quoi ils sont tous
mondialistes nous allons remettre les
choses dans l'ordre ce sera les patriots
contre les mondialistes
parce que c'est ça le vrai problème au
fonds national pour leur réalité
on va parler du ceta de ce traité c'est
du racket est votée par les républicains
et la gauche contre le monde agricole
voilà et ça c'est la vraie ligne qui
reste actuellement c'est patriotes
contre modéliste nous serons les
patriotes on défendra l'union solex par
alors justement en parler nous des
sanctions russe le docu est avec la
russie les gouvernements précédents ont
bloqué les sanctions sont marché russe
on s'est privé de sanction donc la
preuve le front national veut lever ses
sanctions
vous ne vous éloignez la politique
française réponse bien sûr je sois là
dessus justement je crois que la
question qui est posée à chacune chacun
autres candidats à l'assemblée nationale
c'est comment nous voulons battre
évidemment pour des questions qui
intéressent tout le pays
mais en particulier cet autre france qui
n'est pas comme ça naturellement
gagnante dans la mondialisation qui a
des difficultés économiques et sociales
profondes et et en particulier qui a les
problèmes spécifiques de la ruralité
la 4g est générée par les 41 pays
hier j'ai écrit hier une lettre ouverte
au président de la république sur la
ruralité sur l'avenir du monde rural et
je nous invite à nous aider dans ce
combat vous devant l'aja dans la lignée
de cinq ans dans la nièvre en ce temps
là à dire que ça n'est pas ce n'est pas
un problème simplement locale pourquoi
parce que depuis allez les années 80 on
a fait des politiques de la ville avec
parfois des réussites
parfois aussi des échecs on n'a jamais
fait avec suffisamment d'ambition et de
vigueur malgré ce que la nièvre a
souvent demandé lors n'a jamais fait
avec suffisamment dense
de vigueur une politique de la ruralité
et quand on va parler des questions de
santé pour pourquoi est ce que pendant
qu'on la verra ce que ça donne encore
par un essai je ne suis pas le maître
d'armes à l'agenda il faut la mettre au
jour et demain vous parlez de ne pas
faire de monsieur passe jamais on
s'attend à ce qu'ils veulent je sais
très bien alors je dirais en veux tu en
voilà lancé la discussion je parle on y
va s'il vous plaît par l'onf on y va
ferrer est vite on évite d'être
désagréable surtout sur la ruralité le
silence on n'est pas franchement un
rural non plus on avait parlé de 77 ans
candidat de la france est soumise aux
roulant c'est bien ce que des candidats
ruraux il n'y a pas que jean luc
mélenchon nous sommes ce sont 1000 a
soumis de ce pays alors on les rassure
sur la conscription bien sûr absolument
absolument déjà une petit quelque chose
tout de même je crois savoir que le set
a été signé par monsieur hollande ou qui
est en train de monter saison ensuite je
vois ça aussi que je crois savoir
également que madame le pen qui est
parlementaires européens n'étaient pas
vraiment présente à la commission du
commerce international luis magana
l'avons décrit ensuite sur la sur la
ruralité
vous avez fort justement évoquer la
santé ce monsieur paul le la
circonscription dans laquelle je me
présente et plus le premier désert
médical de france pour trouver un
spécialiste pour le désert avance pour
trouver un spécialiste mais nos médecins
généralistes c'est la croix et la
bannière aujourd'hui il y en a plus qu'à
quelques minutes de chez vous un
marinier l'église oui c'est à sainte
lucie le jeune je ne me représente pas
pour ma personne et bien je sais que je
me ferai d'abord assurer comme
j'aimerais jouer parce que dans ses
réponses et si on réunit les ans n'ayant
pas vers sa menace à peine voilée
c'est pour ça que je te présente c'est
parce que ça devient insupportable dont
puisse habiter dans n'importe quelle
dans un endroit en france et qu'on n'ait
pas accès aux premiers principes et la
solution assez d'accord pour
ça va pas en quoi on oblige les médecins
à s'installer ont les peines et les
communes qui les paie déjà on commence
par mettre fin au numerus clausus qui
est qui restreint la possibilité
d'augmenter nous laissant dans notre
pays la chose c'est qu'on re la sorte
est accessible au plus grand nombre
c'est à dire qu'on met fin aux
dépassements d'honoraires
la troisième chose c'est que ce que nous
proposons à la france est soumise ces de
rémunérer les étudiants en médecine de
façon qu après leurs études ils puissent
rendre à l'image des fonctionnaires en
fait rendre à l'état ça leur donnera pas
envie d'aller à la campagne on est ce
que ça donne envie d'aller s'installer à
la campagne commence bien sûr c'est mon
cas si vous faites des études de
médecine c'est très difficile les études
de médecine peut pas travailler à côté
déjà le premier problème c'est qu'un
certain nombre de français qui
souhaiteraient être médecin et d'une
peuvent pas le faire tout simplement
parce que leur famille doit pas les
moyens de subvenir à leurs besoins
nous nous proposons de leur offrir un
salaire pendant leurs études et ensuite
exactement comme par exemple les
enseignants qui le choix entre trois
postes je crois qu'il ya un poste leur
est attribuée ça nous permettra avec les
nouveaux médecins qui seront plus
nombreux puisque nous supprimons numerus
clausus ça nous permettra d'installer
des médecins à la campagne voilà nous
voulons je finis jusque là sur une chose
nous voulons évidemment reconstruire le
système hospitalier qui a été
complètement laminé ces dernières années
c'est une catastrophe absolue
le personnel hospitalier et soignant non
peu plus il ya des suicides en masse là
bas il faut quand même le savoir aux
urgences sont totalement débordés
ce qu'on veut faire c'est contrairement
à ce que par exemple monsieur me qu'on
veut faire ne voulons pas supprimer son
ami l'autre fonctionnaire nouveau gros
bouchée des fonctionnaires je retrouve
en avance pagnol nous parlons d'un
numerus clausus d'accord mais numerus
clausus adp a noté au territoire
c'est à dire que c'est chez nous que
nous avons besoin de médecins et non pas
dans la région parisienne ou dans la
région midi me disent qu'ils vont
réussir à flécher les gens voilà
exactement et leur donner envie de venir
à la campagne il faut rendre rien d'un
énième rendre les campagnes attractive
voilà tout ça veut dire maintenir le
service public oui parce que plus avis
public quitte l'église campagne - elles
sont attractives
non seulement pour les médecins et pour
les propos les professionnels mais aussi
pour les habitants et le problème des
médecins ceux-ci un problème
démographique mondiale monte dans les
campagnes voilà ces spirales
vernal il on est d'accord qu'une
dimension budgétaire maintenant si c'est
à dire que payer payer les étudiants
regardez le service public ça veut dire
aussi une dépense que oui mais je suis
au mieux mener la santé c'est un droit
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il faut
continuer l'implantation des maisons de
santé
nous avons dans la nièvre un taux de
maisons de santé qui est évidemment plus
important que dans beau gaillard
seulement les avionneurs et nous leur
avons créé il faut continuer il faut
probablement également de la médecine
salariée dans ces maisons de santé
parce que la liberté d'installation ne
permet pas aux gentils soir à la
campagne est couverte à l'issue de la
bagarre et médecine parce que ça doit
être moderne en adroit dans les maisons
de santé rurales à des services qui
doivent être au moins aussi performant
qu'en ville et je partage l'idée et j'en
termine je partage l'idée monsieur
perrault temps par 220 mille deux cent
vingt mille suppressions d'emplois dans
les services publics
on est en grande difficulté en par
avance encore l'art avant savez 120000
c'est plus que nicolas sarkozy françois
fillon n'en avait supprimé entre 80
entre 2000 2007 et 2012 et et
franchement il faut mettre un frein à
cette idée fut une récente qui est de
shooter massivement les services vocaux
et puis vos projets aussi sûr je
voudrais surtout à venir c'est que
depuis 13h jeu on est vraiment dans
cette politique de constats un mois
c'est ce qui m'a amené en marche un
c'est de me dire aujourd'hui on a la
possibilité de regarder un petit peu de
vent de chercher les solutions et
d'arrêter de regarder derrière là vous
faites le constat qui a été fait pendant
la période de diagnostic qui s'est abîmé
vers une solution
oui non mais je fais aussi des briques
de l'amusement parce que absolument des
solutions d'entreposage ou tard par
contre aujourd'hui retourné la
représentation politique dans sa
globalité est incapable de s'inscrire
dans l'anticipation et je pense qu'entre
contre les déserts médicaux et en
particulier la nièvre la 2e
circonscription il ya 20 ans on aurait
dû anticiper cette génération 15 ans ils
sont abîmées sales et d'autres cherchent
à les aborder des idées nouvelles
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la bonne nouvelle c'est
qu'on a de nombreux étudiants nivernais
en médecine et qui envisage le retour
sur le territoire grâce au conseil
départemental
bien sûr fortement mais constat qu'on
perde et je vais faire mon compère des
activités je crois qu'il faut qu'on voit
aussi les ressorts qui vont tous les
remèdes et je vous le werder il termine
cette fois aussi en revenir une chose
est un dispositif européen qui s'appelle
la zone franche que vous devez pas
ignorer pourquoi notre deuxième
circonscription ne s'inscrit pas dans ce
dispositif
nous sommes en zone de revitalisation
rurale et on va les gens parti
socialiste en marche s'il vous plaît on
est parents vont changer avec une terre
d'eau à temps et et madame line mais
nous ne sommes pas gêné pour le faire
également
bien évidemment et on était juste pour
que tu es sûr viol n'est pas temps de
parler des ventes qui monte qui monte
qui monte et je vous rappelle que
l'esprit de récup de temps marche aussi
c'est d'avoir un esprit ouvert et d'être
un petit peu à l'écouté de chacun
jim alesi aussi les ressorts qui est
dans notre territoire qui vont permettre
dès janvier un projet parce que bien sûr
on perd des habitants par des activités
mais en fait la nièvre une paire
exportatrices exportatrices de produits
de qualité
on exporte de la viande exporte des
céréales en exporte du bois on exporte
des produits finis de notre de nos
entreprises de niche et de précision
donc on a les ressorts pour faire
grandir notre territoire
je crois qu'il faut qu'on améliore nos
réseaux vous avez raison faut qu'on
essaie d'améliorer le système de santé
vous surtout c'est un mot qu'on n'a pas
prononcé encore vous connaît notre
agriculture l'agriculture est l'activité
principale de notre territoire c'est à
partir du moment où les agriculteurs
vont pouvoir à nouveau avoir un juste
prix à leurs produits produits de
qualité qui peuvent être exportées dans
le monde entier qu'on va pouvoir
revivifier le territoire et des nouveaux
commerçants en effet aider notre système
de santé est également deux écoles il ne
conservait pas il nous reste deux
minutes à votre 2031 des conclusions a
dit le graet et albano sont en retard
donc pas vraiment son temps de parole
ani le grain sur cette circonscription
des propositions que vous voulez faire
passer maintenant
quand on parle de ruralité urbanité la
nièvre a un potentiel tout à fait
exploitable
on n'a pas parlé du tourisme nous avons
deux reporters de fr3 qui sont venus
voir dans nos permanences et qui ont été
éblouis par notre département
le tourisme est vraiment inexploité mais
je crois que déjà il faut que les
nivernais aiment leur département pour
pouvoir
je dirais le vendre parce que possible
de parler agriculture on a parlé santé
alors là je sur le discours ricol c'est
clair qu'il faut absolument remettre la
protection il faut refaire des filières
courtes
il faut se battre dans cette voie là ça
c'est que les front national fera
maintenant dans la nièvre et d'autres
choses que j'aimerais combattre et que
personne n'évoque ce sont les éoliennes
nous avons un gouvernement de ce
maquereau qui veut doubler le parc
éolien de france
je pense que mettre des éoliennes dans
la nièvre s'est manqué cruellement de
vision stratégique parce que pour le
tourisme
savage et le tourisme le tourisme n'est
donc pas dans la nièvre trouver des
éoliennes alors qu'ils venaient chercher
du calme et la verdure bon monsieur
blanot tout de suite il n'y a pas de
projets éoliens sur cette somme
nivernaise si si si si monsieur habib sy
saint sulpice je les soutiens ça jamais
des fois je le soutiendrai pas présent
en tout cas votre mouvement le mouvement
le fait est qu'elle ne l'aurait pas pour
une bonne raison c'est qu'on est l'un
des départements les moins avant tout de
france oui mais justement et malgré sa
très grand projet éolien comme pas une
aberration dès bien sûr mais on va
s'intéresser au projet éolien porté
partie monsieur blaney et parthenay est
soutenu par votre majorité bien monsieur
monsieur macron s'exprimer là dessus je
crois sur france inter il avait vu
doubler le parc éolien
il me semble quand même intéressant de
parler de l'éolien dans les
renouvelables n'ont bien sûr pas
d'énergie
et le soleil et que je sais ni pourquoi
je suis et enfin enfin elle arrive à la
fin de ce débat d'écouté je suis
vraiment très jeune j'ai vu que j'avais
d'autres éléments et si elle ne
fonctionnait à supprimer sur les 128
70000 dans la fonction publique
territoriale et dirige aux arènes vie ça
passe plus c'est l'heure des conclusions
parce que pour les téléspectateurs les
gens de l'yonne attendent dans l'ombre
du belge ou bien je suis pour prendre
votre place juste après merci d'avoir
des battus jusque là 30 secondes chacun
deux conclusions dans un ordre tirés au
sort préalablement l'a fait juste avant
cette émission
merci de respecter la règle et la durée
et on commence en conclusion par harold
blanot pour le front national
alors si je suis élu je serai le député
déclarera vraiment la guerre au
terrorisme
seul le front national et les mesures
l'expérience des conclusions pour le
faire voilà ensuite pour la nièvre je
veux absolument parler des agriculteurs
ce sont les grands oubliés des dernier
quinquennat il faut absolument défendre
le monde agricole français
le modèle d'exposition familiale et
enfin pour la nièvre
effectivement si je suis élu je
demanderai un moratoire sur ces
éoliennes merci harold l'anneau à suivre
la conclusion danilo gras investi par un
public et bien moi je suis révolté je
suis révoltée de voir cette 1e kylie se
dépeuple qui vieillit qui perd ses
emplois qui perd ses jeunes
on ne peut pas faire du neuf avec de
l'ancien jeu alors essayons autre chose
je vous propose être une députée une
députée à vos côtés c'est auprès d'aînés
vernet après nous rencontrent nos
diverses aisée chance que j'ai appris
pourquoi je voulais m'engager pour eux
et pour la nième merci annie legrand
christian paul je crois que si on veut
servir la nièvre il ne faut pas de
dénigrer
il faut au contraire apporter des idées
neuves le faire du neuf c'est apporter
des idées neuves
on a parlé de la santé on aurait pu
parler des réseaux numériques de la
fibre optique
glandières très haut débit qui va se
déployer dans l'essentiel de la nièvre
al donc c'est vrai je souhaite être un
des buts est utile pour la république
pour la france bien sûr et pour la
nièvre également parce que nous sommes à
un moment de notre histoire nous avons
besoin de mieux défendre les français
parce qu'on voit bien les risques et les
menaces et puis aussi d'apporter à ce
pays meurtri un projet optimiste
merci christian paul fabienne cardo elle
a l'ambition que j'ai avec vous et c'est
de développer lanières de la mettre en
mouvement
le député ne peut pas tout on le sait
bien mais il peut changer le cadre de
notre terre et vous permettre de
développer vos projets et puis la
volonté que j'ai avec vous c'est de
faire de la politique autrement
alors aujourd'hui je me présente à la
législative et je prends deux
engagements concrets devant vous que je
tiendrais réunir en trois réunions
publiques chaque année la population qui
le souhaite pour rendre compte et pour
écouter et un deuxième engagement
mettre en place une fondation à laquelle
je verserai une partie de ma rétribution
de déployer afin d'aider les jeunes
agriculteurs à s'installer que la
création de l'entreprise dans la nièvre
et je demanderai à hiverner fiers de
leur territoire de contribuer à cette
fondation
merci fabien cardo marianne dean écoutez
je crois que la nièvre n'est pas à
vendre
je crois aussi que avant de songer à
exporter tous azimuts
il faudrait peut-être commencer par
répondre aux besoins des nivernais des
français de façon générale vous parler
d'agriculture
le programme de la france ou soumise
pour l'agriculture ça représente 300
mille nouveaux paysans qui peuvent
s'installer et y compris dans les zones
rurales qui se désertifient ça
représente également une énorme avancée
pour la santé publique puisque nous
voulons une agriculture respectueuse
environnement biologique c'est possible
sur l'ensemble du territoire
ça représente des emplois et ça
représente un renouveau également pour
le département et pour l'ensemble des
zones rurales de notre pays merci
patrice perron oui je veux être le
député pour les nivernaise et pour les
nivernais un député qui libère qui
protège dirais comme sidi qui exploite
les valeurs de notre département et il y
en a dans l'agriculture dans
l'exploitation par un forestière dans le
service
dans l'art dans chez nos artisans
je veux être ce député pour réconcilier
également l'action de l'état et protéger
les nivernais de l'univers
merci merci patrice perron merci à tous
les six d'avoir accepté notre invitation
pour ce débat qui va très vite je le
sais bien je le lis dans vos yeux
et pendant que vous quittez ce plateau
merci à vous et bon retour
je précise que sept autres candidats se
présentent sur cette 2e circonscription
il s'agit de gens de rohan chabot pour
l'upm gilbert champagne pour europe
ecologie les verts henry massol patrie
devant air sec pour dnf marque monique
choquel pour le parti communiste bernard
gagne pain 100 % et dominique dupuy pour
lutte ouvrière est notre deuxième
plateau est en train de s'installer
je vérifie vous êtes tous à la bonne
place formidable
tout a bien marché merci à tous les six
de nous avoir rejoints nous passons donc
au deuxième débat de cette matinée nous
partons dans l'yonne au nord de l'yonne
dans la troisième circonscription sens
joigny circonscription particulière avec
de l'urbain du périurbain du rural et
une grande proximité géographique avec
l'île de france un débat en partenariat
avec l'yonne républicaine or le
rédacteur en chef stéphane vergeade à me
rejoindre pendant ce débat pour parler
de la circonscription
c'est marie louise fort qui représentait
cette circonscription à l'assemblée
depuis 2007 pour les républicains
elle a décidé de ne pas se représenter
pour ces élections législatives
quinze candidats en lice et parmi eux
nos six invités bonjour clarisse
qu'entame bonjour vous êtes pour cette
élection la candidate des républicains
julien audy bonjour bonjour porter les
couleurs du front national dominique
bourreau pour le ps bonjourbonjour
monique michel crouzet pardon vous êtes
à candidate de la république en marche
lors il allait me chaut la france est
soumise
bonjour et des films grémy ou vous
présenter sans parti et sans investiture
vengeance et l excision bonjour pour
mieux vous connaître et vous comprendre
vous
on l'a fait pour le débat précédent nous
vous proposons donc de vous présenter de
nous dire quelles sont vos motivations
va falloir être con si vous avez 30
secondes chacun
nous avons tiré au sort préalablement
l'ordre de passage et c'est vous je
viens au 12 il commençait oui bonjour et
merci monsieur mêlée nous avoir invités
pour pour ce débat nous sommes six
aujourd'hui et je regrette que
finalement nous les neuf autres
candidats donc à cette élection
législative sur la troisième
circonscription de l'aisne ne soit pas
présent pour moi en tout cas nous sommes
tous à égalité donc devant le regard des
français c'est dommage qu'ils ne
puissent pas participer et s'exprimer si
on sur ma présentation finalement elle
importe peu puisque ce qui importait
surtout les difficultés et les attentes
de nos compatriotes mais en quelques
mots pour représenter donc j'ai 32 ans
je suis un jeune français engagé
amoureux de notre pays de ses racines de
son histoire
j'ai aussi un jeune france français
engagés auprès de marine le pen pour
remettre la france en ordre je suis
aussi un élu de proximité qui ne
supporte pas l'abandon de notre
territoire et les difficultés nos
compatriotes
et puis je suis aussi un jeune français
est un jeune citoyen qui ne supporte
plus aussi l'accoutumance au terrorisme
islamiste
on va en parler et je vous coupe parce
que vous êtes très très très très
largement dépassé les 30 secondes
bonjour je sillonne notre département
depuis près de 20 ans en tant que chef
d'entreprise et mandataires syndicale
bénévoles conseillère municipale et
départementale j'ai toujours refusé le
prêt-à-penser des grandes franchises
politique qui est prétendu décidé pour
les français sont les représenter je
connais bien le territoire sédhiou ses
institutions et partenaires des moyens
professionnels et des représentants de
l'état
je vais incarner une nouvelle génération
d'hommes et de femmes politiques
sincères et exemplaires qui seront
produits dans les intérêts des citoyens
et non par ceux d'un parti si je suis
élu j'appliquerai trois grands principes
exemplarité transparence et obligation
de résultat
merci j'ai chaud alors je suis de joigny
j'ai 45 ans je représente la france
insoumise donc je vais pas épiloguer sur
mon vécu sur ce que je fais je fais deux
soignantes j'ai trois enfants c'est pas
plus important c'est surtout là pour
représenter les mécontents ceux qui se
sont mis de notre côté les cinq cent
mille personnes à sony qui nous ont déjà
rejoints tous ceux qui veulent aussi
nous rejoindre pour voir enfin la
députation quelqu'un qui ne fera pas
partie des magouilles
pareil quelqu'un qui défendra enfin les
intérêts des citoyens et des citoyennes
des jeunes comme des moins jeunes ça va
faire du monde et je vais tout faire
pour les convaincre
merci dominique baud bien je suis issu
de l'apprentissage et je suis rentré
dans la vie active à 14 ans comme
ouvrier du bâtiment formateur
d'apprentis puis entrepreneurs en 2008
et habitants de villeneuve la guyard
m'ont porté maire de la commune commune
de 3500 habitants la plus endettée du
département de l'yonne et nous avons
dressé des finances de la commune sans
augmentation des taux des taxes
je suis également en responsabilité du
développement économique au sein de la
communauté de communes yonne nord et
nous travaillons en ce moment pour
revitaliser les friches industrielles
je les soutiens du parti socialiste
d'europe écologie les verts et du parti
radical de gauche pour cette élection
merci clarisse quand donc je suis une
enfant la circonscription mère de trois
enfants est chef d'entreprise je suis
élu depuis 2014 en charge de l'emploi et
la formation à la mairie de sens et
depuis 2015 conseiller départemental je
suis est également présidente de deux
associations d'insertion
j'ai un bon bilan des dispositifs
innovants et efficaces en matière de
lutte contre le chômage et d'insertion
que je souhaite défendre au niveau
national c'est le sens de ma candidature
porter les bonnes pratiques et les
réussites de notre territoire à
l'assemblée nationale la prochaine
assemblée sera fortement renouvelée dans
ce contexte ma candidature qui allie
renouvellement et expérience a toute sa
place
merci bonjour je suis la candidate de la
république en marche je suis chef
d'entreprise juge a joint dans ma
commune à evry conseillère communautaire
et vice-présidente au conseil
départemental et j'ai en charge la
commission agriculture et environnement
mes priorités sur pour la
circonscription sont axées sur son
attractivité en afin d'en améliorer le
développement économique et le cadre de
vie pour tous
cela passe pour moi par le développement
de tous les moyens de communication qui
seront le très haut débit tous les types
de transport et l'accès des services au
public 1 pour qu'il profite à tous il
est urgent de libérer les énergies tout
en protégeant les citoyens et d'être
garante donc de la moralisation de la
vie politique
merci michel crouzet merci à tous les
six pour cette brève présentation pour
tous ces débats on a fait le même choix
qui est d'abord de commencer par un
chapitre politique
parce qu'on est derrière une
présidentielle qui a été un petit peu
particulière et julien odoul je voulais
commencer par vous en rappelant que
beaucoup de gens regardent cette
circonscription en fonction des scores
élevés du front national 41 % aux
régionales 31% au premier tour de la
présidentielle
ça vous placent en position de favori de
cette élection législative je sais pas
cela me place enfin position de favori
en tout cas ça m'oblige
ça m'oblige à faire gagner les habitants
du nord de l'yonne qui rentreront avec
moi l'assemblée nationale qui seront
réellement défendu le 7 mai dernier
on a assisté donc à la continuité
puisque les français ont porté et manel
hollande donc à la présidence de la
république
ça n'a pas été le choix de la majorité
des habitants du nord de l'yonne qui ont
porté marine le pen donc largement donc
en tête et marine le pen et le front
national est le premier parti de cette
circonscription et moi ce que je
souhaite lors de ceux de cette élection
c'est d'apporter la clarification
je suis le candidat de la vérité je suis
le véritable candidat de l'opposition
la seule opposition crédible sans
compromission amené le maquereau à vous
avez prononcé le mot position c'est ce
qui peut nous arriver où je voulais dire
en tête au premier tour
le cumul et delà du deuxième tour est
d'ailleurs rappelé en marge légèrement
mais favorable puisque puisque madame
c'est en tant que deuxième candidate
fait c'est important de le dire le film
nationale n'est pas majoritaire dans les
fagnes à syrte 200 candidates de
monsieur m'attendent à dire puisque
monsieur macron à deux représentantes
avec la candidate officielle et la
candidate officieuse qui a appelé à
voter pour lui au second tour n'est pas
à voter pour lui si tout à fait
abandonné à marine le pen
cet élément de langage est important
pour moi
il faut l'assumer même quand j'assume ce
que j'ai appelé à voter contre marine
vous pouvez même d'appeler à voter j'ai
expliqué nous avons travaillé nous aller
contre la droite vous avez tant d autres
attendent patiemment pour commencer pas
trahi personne j'ai clarifié mon road
qui était un vote contre marine le pen
alors vous révéler de mâcon
majorité-opposition dominique bourreau
vous êtes saoul alors même si le parti
socialiste entre eux
bernard carayon mais je me situe très
clairement moi je ferai pour la réussite
de mon pays bien évidemment mais en
étant vigilant et constructif et cette
vigilance et cette construction ne fera
repousser la confiance qui sera présenté
par le gouvernement d'edouard philippe
mais derrière ça ne sera pas sans nuance
j'ai la capacité et je souhaite
construire travailler sur la justice
sociale sur l'éducation la santé
l'environnement et son accès pour tous
donc pas de confiance a priori au
gouvernement une grande vigilance est
également le besoin de construire de
construire pour le pays je poursuis
après ce qu'avait dit clarisse quentin
vous êtes 3 à appartenir à la même
majorité au conseil départemental de
l'yonne les beaux je suis pour
l'ensemble des baux l'union de la
majorité de droite ont donc il faut vous
nous disiez tout les 3 par rapport à ce
positionnement salle du temps libre
entre alice et ses lecteurs j'ai été élu
sur l'étiquette
lr udi à l'époque je suis toujours l
érudit voilà alors ce n'est pas le cas
il est bon composition je n'ai jamais eu
aucune étiquette politique sur le
territoire ça c'est une chose qui est
sûre en tout cas la quille échéance
qu'elle est reçue aujourd'hui sûrement
pas son affiche non tu te trompes
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que
depuis 30 ans les parties se déchirent
le pouvoir en france avec les résultats
qu'on connaît
c'est une certitude et les français sont
toujours les victimes de ce système là
aujourd'hui
les élections ont créé montré le rejet
massif des français des systèmes en
place et des politiques politiciennes
ma conviction profonde c'est qu'il est
grand temps d'en finir avec ces ce match
caricatural majorité opposition qui ne
mènent à rien
il est grand temps de faire une vraie
démocratie à l'assemblée et de laisser
la place à toutes les influences
politiques qui remontent les français si
je suis élu je ne serai pas dans
l'opposition systématique stériles qui
ne mènent à rien mon intérêt est ma
conviction c'est de porter mes
compétences et mon énergie au
développement du territoire
il ya la place pour ce genre de
coordination on va repartir je ne trahis
pas non plus personne
de toute façon au niveau du département
le département était sous lui dit quand
même le noter quand même si les rm bien
marc keller udi mais il y avait pas une
sensibilité sur l'idée du diy puisque le
président andré villiers était de lui
dit et de l'udps est donc là faut quand
même leur place et les choses pour n'a
pas il part sur la 2e circonscription
est là
déi que vous allez adam sacré quand même
une vraie confusion enfin peu importe le
mouvement en marche
être en marche voilà c'est ça c'est de
rassembler et comme le soulignait
delphine grémy voilà c'est pas possible
on recommence sur des batailles des
clivages droite gauche qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire
rassemblons les forces vives enfin vous
essayez de majorité à les rues d'alger
jusqu'au 6 mai 2009 met en mouvement en
marche est capable de rassembler les
forces vives jeu on est capable de
rassembler là ne pas conserver la mi mai
par rapport pour le front national par
contient un autre cap là on est on est
un barrage qui doit être fait contre le
front national parce que vos précautions
vous avez le sont toutes là qu'ils
voient non nous avons et vous avez voilà
et bien tant mieux parce
qu'effectivement c'est de votre parti ce
n'est pas politique et je suis ravi que
les téléspectateurs puissent comprendre
grâce à vos interventions
qu'effectivement vous tous et vous tout
avait des a déjà siégé soit par le biais
de votre personne soit par le biais de
vos parties que vous siégez encore au
conseil départemental dans diverses
municipalités et qu'effectivement le
résultat en tout cas pour la deuxième
circonscription de l'yonne il est celui
qui l'est alors pour la 3e
circonscription de l'yonne pardon ça
veut bien dire que la réussite n'est pas
là ni pour vos parties ni pour les uns
ni pour les autres camps pour quand on
parle de regroupement justement c'est
aussi la confirmation l'a vu avec
emmanuel macron il a réussi
effectivement né dans le même sac
des gens des hommes des femmes de tous
bords fins de tous bords du même bord
qui mouillent systématiquement aux mêmes
magouilles
il s'est quand même hallucinant quand je
veux dire entre le pro areva l'europe et
européiste
ils sont plusieurs bea entre les
magouilles d'appareils
ce qui est extraordinaire que tous
effectivement ce soir rejoint se
prennent la main et se disent ensemble
on va bien pouvoir travailler à la seule
opposition ça doit être les députés les
futurs députés de la france insoumise
qui eux ont réussi à rassembler et à
fédérer des gens qui ne voulaient plus
voter des gens qui disaient toujours on
les a sur les marchés en lisant les
réunions publiques toutes façons c'est
tous des pourris maintenant j rep vous
pensez y aura autant de participation
aux législatives il ya toujours aux
législatives de toute façon de tout
temps une
l'importante abstention de mon espère
réussir à faire venir l'achat moins de
temps en temps je voudrais dire que très
clairement j'ai appelé à voter emmanuel
macron au deuxième tour je ne voulait
aucune ambiguïté ce qui a été le cas de
beaucoup pour faire barrage au front
national parce que je me pose très
clairement au front national
monsieur odoul le sait parfaitement n'ai
eu l'occasion de se confronter face
plusieurs fois et on va dire les choix
aux tiède je ne sais pas je dis pas pour
qui je vote mais je vote pas quand même
c'est quelque chose d'absolument pas
claires donc mon choix était clair
macron pour faire barrage au front
national et je m'engouffre pour ouvrir
la deuxième partie de cette émission je
vous propose d'accueillir sur ce plateau
stéphane vergeade de rédacteur en chef
de l'yonne républicaine que notre
partenaire bonjour stéphane merci merci
d'être avec nous on voulait parler de
votre circonscription et stéphane qui
travaillent dans l'yonne la connaît
particulièrement bien
on s'était dit qu'il y avait un concept
à la mode pour parler de la troisième de
l'yonne c'était la france qui est
récurrent si la france périphérique de
christophe guilluy tout à l'heure on
entre et christian paul qui parlait
votre france cette france un peu des
campagnes en lisière des métropoles qui
souffre parfois d'une fracture d'un
oubli à l'abandon on le voit avec le
sort du fn notamment cette cirque où
vous le savez tous elle est
particulièrement complexe les pluriels
elle appelle sans doute des réponses et
des solutions complexes entre un
territoire qui à la lisière de la région
parisienne qui n'est pas tout à fait
bourguignon qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce
qu'on fait de ce territoire qu'est ce
que vous voulez mettre en place pour ce
territoire pour faire justement un vrai
territoire actif le mot a été prononcé
tout à l'heure avec des vrais levier
économique et de développement question
d'une chance il ya une chance
démographique de grandir ce qu'est ce
que vous allez faire vous si vous êtes
et ceux qui mettent la couverture du
serbe puis ça va être un onze minutes
plyce quentin donc dans le programme
elle est rudy pour 7 pour ces
législatives
nous avons la mise en place d'une agente
de développement rural veut dire qu'on
s'engage pour tout euro investi dans les
villes à investir un euro dans les
campagnes c'est extrêmement important le
vote front faut pas se leurrer c'est un
oubli de la ruralité je fais le tour
tous les jours des petits villages c'est
un oubli de la ruralité il faut lutter
là dessus il faut lutter contre ça
effectivement je connais bien un
territoire c'est un territoire qui est
encore à ses industriels et là sur le
sur le thème industrielle il faut
absolument continuer à développer la
formation professionnelle et je vais lui
témoins pour décloisonner l'enseignement
général et lente et les filières des
filières pro puisque sur le sur le
bassin sénonais on a de nombreuses
offres d'emploi qui sont non pourvus par
défaut de formation du des demandeurs
d'emploi monsieur moussa
particulièrement implantée en zone
rurale jeu sommes pas sens prêt pour
finalement contre mais pour vous avez
perdu
oui on est en léger retard mais j'ai ont
fait des scores extraordinaire dans
toutes les petites communes et je dois
dire que moi mon programme d'engagement
c'est de lutter contre la fracture
territoriale 1 que territorial qu'on
parlait de france périphérique moi je
parle de france des oubliés avec que nos
compatriotes qui ont totalement été
sorti des écrans radar donc par les
gouvernements de droite et de gauche
avec donc désertification quel soin
médical qu'elle soit des services
publics pour proposer concrètement je
propose déjà la première des priorités
c'est déjà de rétablir la sécurité
nous avons un territoire donc qui
souffre notamment de l'explosion des
cambriolages faut savoir qu'on est un
quatre à cinq cambriolages par jour sur
le nord de l'yonne 14e édition qui a
progressé ces dernières années c'est
énorme et tout ça c'est lié évidemment
donc à la suppression d'un stand de
gendarmerie et à la baisse des effectifs
donc des forces de sécurité donc moi je
propose dans une majorité patriotes donc
le recrutement de 15 mille policiers
gendarmes et qu'ils soient affectés
prioritairement donc sur les zones
rurales bizarrement dans l'yonne ratures
assurément non en tout cas les gendarmes
seront affectés prioritairement la
sécurité évidemment désertification
médicale
on est à moins d'un généraliste pour
1000 habitants sur le territoire c'est
énorme
donc les conséquences sont dramatiques
ont cessé sur mortalité infantile c'est
une baisse de l'espérance de vie on et
90e dans l'yonne sur son département
c'est inadmissible et puis ensuite tu
reprends parce que je crois qu on assure
l'égalité des droits et des chances
moi je propose donc la gratuité du
permis de conduire pour les jeunes de
moins de 25 ans donc dans les
territoires ruraux ou désertifiés pour
qu'ils puissent justement avons accès à
la formation et à l'emploi se creuser
pour développer notre notre pour eux
pour distribuer de la richesse pardon il
faut créer pour distribuer du pouvoir
d'achat il faut redonner de la richesse
d'un autre département
là le développement économique va se
passer par mois pour moi c'est le grand
plan de l'amélioration dé toutes les
réseaux de 30 de transport et de
communication
absolument qu'on se développe au niveau
du très haut débit au niveau des
campagnes et de l'internet focaliser des
os deviennent les entreprises en aidant
les grévistes pour qu'une entreprise
puisse s'installer lui faut du très haut
débit c'est la première chose qui nous
est demandé même dans les campagnes on
ne la leçon pour accéder aux services
les services au public et bien il faut
aussi du débit du haut débit dans les
petites campagnes parce qu'on va créer
des maisons de service public dans l'est
ce n'était pas vraiment une priorité
départementale du haut débit
ça l'est aujourd'hui quand même oui et
un nul à lens qui fait valoir appuyé il
va falloir appuyer cela au niveau
national pourquoi ce retard donne pour
trier par des prêtres ou nouveau pris
trente ans de retard au département sur
le débat au département a pris du retard
sur le sur le haut débit alors ça c'est
vrai qu effectivement y'a pas eu les
politiques qui ont été faites au moment
voulu et à partir de ce moment là c'est
vrai que maintenant quand il faut le
mettre en place
ça nous coûte beaucoup d'argent et en
même temps faut noter que au niveau des
des opérateurs téléphoniques s'apprêtait
forcément très simple non plus le
constat est terrible pour le département
alors voilà on va continuer alors allez
aller au bout de ces conditions le
frapperait l'avons commencé vous avez à
faire juste le constat terrible pour le
département vous parlez d eau d dit je
suppose que d'autres voilà le mejhoul et
non vous attaquez les trois conseils
départementale si je comprends bien de
majorité au oui non
mais pour le président andré caillé d'un
cancer du côlon qui ne sera là ce après
vidéo wii territoriales je pense qu'il
ya un outil important qui se met en
place jusqu'à aujourd'hui la troisième
circonscription comme beaucoup étaient
une circonscription électorale sans
cohérence et que sans cohésion mais
aujourd'hui il ya le pôle d'équilibré
riz taurian rural qui se met en place et
qui se met en place sur justement le
périmètre de certifier conscription qui
va lui permettre de trouver une
véritable identité territoriale à
travers la coopération des communautés
de communes et de la communauté dacquois
c'est un organisme qui fait marcher les
collectivités en ce sens n'est pas un
organisme c'est les communes les
communautés de communes et les
communautés d'agglo qui se réunissent
sur le territoire pour pouvoir créer un
outil d'aménagement de développement
durable pour pouvoir avoir accès au
levier et notamment au levier financier
via la région et l'europe et on a abordé
des problèmes par points est justement
une partie de ses problèmes avec cet
outil pourront être résolus
c'est un outil de première importance et
je pense que le territoire va bientôt en
prendre conscience
avec une vision à 20 ans il n'y avait
qu'une vision très très long terme
d'accords que mais on parlait par
certains socialistes qui de président
est supposé cgem c'est qu'il faille de
coordination a voté contre au départ au
à la région c'est quand même important
c'est intéressant bien c'est une usine à
gaz qui était rapporté le développement
du territoire et vous vous aurez delà
les clivages politiques fois au et de la
région vous allez voter contre les
candidats et des clivages solide où
lille vous avez vous c'est un outil mois
les congés chiralité 2007 à être 2020
c'est un outil politique c'est un outil
de constituer à terme une partie ce
serait plus rien j'en profite pour vous
couper
j'admire le fait que vous preniez à
coeur de parler de zones blanches de cet
outil vous allez même jusqu'à nous
expliquer à nos électeurs et candidats
que c'est un outil indispensable pour
l'yonne on se rend compte quand même là
qu'on est juste complètement déconnectés
de la réalité
quelques complètement alors là au sens
propre comme au sens figuré quand même
parce que permettez moi de vous rappeler
que ce que les gens là sont en train de
souffrir dans la troisième
circonscription de l'yonne et bien sûr
aussi ailleurs du manque d'emploi du
monde de médecins de la précarité
on n'est pas en train de se demander si
on réussit à avoir internet chez soi là
on est en train de se demander comment
on fait pour emmener les enfants à
l'école quand ya pas de faculté n'y a
rien comme on fait pour que nos enfants
fassent des études
on en est là on est en train de se
demander comment on fait pour aller
accoucher quand on est enceinte et qu'on
est en plein milieu de la campagne et
que le poêle à coucher faut aller
jusqu'à sens jusqu'à auxerre on est en
train de se poser cette question là qui
sont existentielle les retraités se
demande comment ils font pour continuer
de vivre avec un indice qui est gelé
depuis dix ans avec justement vos
gouvernants qui se sont succédé les uns
après les autres et qui n'ont jamais de
toute façon rien fait pour que ça évolue
et là vous nous parler et du haut débit
c'est formidable je suis content d'avoir
internet chez moi enfin à longs poils
abuse on va essayer de recentrer son
élection
vous ne cherchez vous ne pouvez pas
chercher un emploi sans internet
aujourd'hui vous en rendrez compte on
parlait du chômage mais vous pouvez pas
chercher vous pouvez faire faire de
démarche ni vous inscrire à pôle emploi
d'ailleurs
savoir internet c'est ça s'appelle la
dématérialisation et ça s'appelle la
casse qui s'appelle j'aurais parlé à
maintes fois et de l'emploi des jeunes
je pense qu'il faut développer
l'alternance en deux séquences cription
de manière massive au lycée porté
uniquement par les tpe et les pme et les
jeunes sont au chômage
il faut aussi monter des partenariats
avec la seine-et-marne pour créer des
filières de formation on a quatre coins
de paris qui s'en vont du département
chaque année c'est énorme
donc aujourd'hui il ya un focus à mettre
sur l'emploi se sont intéressés par ce
genre de choses on avait la télé par
brainiac en générer du flux s'agira de
la consommation ça améliorera le
commerce
il faut aussi améliorer le logement
effectivement de nos concitoyens est
vraiment des sujets propres qui sont qui
sont traités sur le télex vers
économique de la troisième
circonscription passe par un
rapprochement avec l'argent président
oui nous sommes davantage seine-et-marne
et que bourguignon c'est un fait
un set découpage d'une sortie n'est pas
toujours cohérent aujourd'hui nous avons
tiré vers le haut c'est important nous
sommes à tonner invisible il faut en
finir avec cette situation
elle passe par la formation par la
formation professionnelle effectivement
parce qu' un certain nombre
d'entreprises ne trouve plus les la main
d'oeuvre qu'il cherche sur le terril en
bois au départ ils vont finir par partir
ailleurs
donc il faut absolument travailler ce
point là alors je parlais de tous les
moyens de communication aidons aussi la
mobilité la mobilité qui se fait aussi à
travers les moyens de transport parce
que il ya beaucoup de salariés ont
interrogé des dans les agences d'intérim
vous pouvez voir on pouvait pas les on
peut pas recruter on peut pas envoyer
des intérimaires dans des entreprises
parce qu'ils ont plus soyons plus ils
ont permis ou bien qu'ils puissent on
puisse favoriser déjà en fait les
transports vers les entreprises et qui
on facilite aussi pour pour c est pour
ces jeunes la nervosité pas ses pertes
sur nationale pour vous ça c'est des
mesures nationales qui seront j'espère
que l'avenir pour un jeune c'est pas de
se retrouver intérimaire cevital pas
forcément intérimaire mais pour trouver
un emploi
j'ai voulu recruter dans mon entreprise
j'ai pas pris quelqu'un parce qu'il
n'avait pas le permis et parce qu'il est
technicien il doit les déplacer sur des
chantiers c'est pas possible donc du
coup c'est quand même est fondamental de
pouvoir donner un plan ont permis de
conduire effectivement avec une
important oui avec une aide ou on cumule
les aides département-région mission
locale ville est belle comme cette
mobilité donc je parlais du permis de
conduire donc c'est très important
puisque les jeunes donc deux territoires
n'ont pas les mêmes droits et pas les
mêmes chances pas vraiment les parisiens
ça existait déjà
oui c'est dérisoire dérisoire c'est très
disputée sur 159 vous avez contribue
d'ailleurs à l'appauvrir c'est pas gagné
ça c'est pas la question et ça concerne
tout le sur chaque oeil sur les
questions de mobilité
c'est très important notamment auprès de
transports d'arrêter cette course la
suppression des guichets de gare
donc je me suis opposée notamment la
suppression des gardes des guichets à
villeneuve la guyard à champigny à
villeneuve sur yonne puisque notre
territoire pour nos élites parisiennes
n'est pas rentable
c'est qu'on considère que ce soit pour
le numérique que ce soit pour les
transports que ce soit pour les médecins
qu'il faut le vider puisqu'il n'ya pas
cette population et que cette population
est totalement méprisé donc il faut
rétablir ça et c'est tout le sens de mon
engagement
sauf que rétablir la vérité et nous
refusons que rétablir l'ouverture des
gares où 2 c'est quand même non c'est
pas un député qui va décider c'est le
conseil régional
on va partager le faire aux campeurs ne
le précise l'ofj est orga toujours de
très important puisque nous avons une
conférence régionale
nous avons énormément de navetteurs sur
le département et c'est vrai qu'il ya un
effet de seuil considérable avec l'île
de france aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui
prend le train dans le département un
régulier un navetteur un coût du billet
qui est trois fois supérieur à celui
qu'il prend à partir des gares de
montereau donc quelque part c'est le
rôle de l'état de faire le
le gendarme auprès des régions pour
pouvoir absolument écrêté ce problème
est qu'il ya un problème énorme si on
augmentera sûrement pas mais il faut
surtout arrêter de faire en sorte à ce
que les gens puissent à soit obligé de
lâcher du travail en région parisienne
ils prennent le temps de parler de
trouver d'autres qualités des secours à
la personne et des pompiers il en manque
50 ans sur le territoire je voudrais
créer un vrai statut pour les pompiers
volontaires du département
oui mais ça ne va soulever important de
secours à la personne en eau créant un
vrai statut en reconnaissant la
préfecture une entreprise ce n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui
en permettant une formation hors congés
payés et en apportant un vrai service de
proximité créé des maisons de santé créé
des maisons décentes maternelle ce sont
des sujets quotidiens pour nos salariés
et je profite pour vous couper pour vous
dire qu'on arrive à la fin de ce débat
excellent moment des conclusions 30
secondes chacun aura non tirées au sort
préalablement merci on dit à tout le
monde de respecter la règle de prendre
secondes et on commence vous avez ma
parole et vous allez là gardée par
dancing rennais pour votre conclusion
oui merci est bien citoyen icaunais
peuvent compter sur moi pour les
représenter loin de tout intérêt
particuliers ou partisans et loin de
tout clientélisme
je serai une candidate indépendante à
leur service l'emploi l'éducation la
sécurité le handicap la formation sont
des sujets que je veux développer sur le
territoire de manière importante je
mettrai mon franc parler mon énergie et
mes compétences à leur service avec la
réserve parlementaire je veux créer une
bourse initiative pour tous les citoyens
et développer des projets structurants
créateurs d'emplois et offrant un
service de proximité
merci de venir en suisse quand j'ai
entendu le cri de détresse de la
ruralité de nos concitoyens qui ne se
sentent pas entendus par les élus face à
cela on a un programme macro qui prévoit
la baisse du pouvoir d'achat en
augmentant la csg c'est pas une solution
ou un parti qui vit qui
instrumentalisent le désarroi sans
apporter de solution au problème
notre pays mérite mieux mon offre de
services et de mettre à profit mon
expérience et mes compétences pour
travailler avec courage dès le 19 juin
la défense de mes premiers combats
l'égalité des territoires la sécurité de
tous et l'emploi l'assemblée nationale
je bénéficierai de la force d'un groupe
parlementaire
autant je garderai mon indépendance et
mon franc parler
en ne votant pas forcément le doigt sur
la couture que je fais au département je
n'ai pas voté les hausses d'impôts qui
n'étaient pas nécessaires
joseph a voce et je n'ai pas fauté je
n'ai pas voté les hausses d'impôts et je
n'ai pas forcé la fermeture d'un collège
de proximité et on sera là merci oui je
voudrais venir sur du très concret
aujourd'hui j'ai visité les 115 communes
j'ai rencontré les élus et les habitants
on a un constat une sécheresse dans le
gall en ce moment il ya 30 % des
agriculteurs une baisse de 30% sur les
récoltes de céréales à venir il ya des
mesures agro environnementales qui sont
mal écrite mal écrite et qui ne
permettent pas de protéger notre
environnement il faut il faut les
réécrire et pour ça il faut des parcs
des parlementaires qui avec le non cumul
des mandats soit des parlementaires à
temps plein s'ensuivirent l'écriture des
technocrates mais en initiant cette
écriture
c'est quelque chose de très important le
travail du parlementaire
c'est le travail de l'écriture l'adapter
au terrain c'est juste que je suis
capable de faire c'est ce que je
porterai merci de migros genève
moi je n'ai pas de notes je n'ai pas
d'éléments de langage mais c'est le
coeur qui va parler moi si l'endroit est
inventé moi si je suis candidat donc
c'est pour être un réel députés
d'opposition pour défendre mes
compatriotes à l'assemblée
je serai un député sans compromission et
un député dont une opposition ferme à la
politique de monsieur macro donc c'est à
dire un député qui s'opposera à des
régulations à la destruction du code du
travail l immigration massive à
l'accoutumance au terrorisme islamiste
au communautarisme je serai aussi donc
un député qui pourra rassembler
largement tous ceux et toutes celles qui
n'ont pas fait le choix des manuels
macro et je porterai aussi le
renouvellement le renouvellement des
pratiques et le ma première décision à
première proposition de loi sera la
baisse des indemnités des députés de 20%
et la transparence surtout les frais
dans le cadre du mandat
merci je viens deux jeunes gens merci
très vite être député de la france
soumise aujourd'hui c'est être pour la
révocabilité des élus personne n'en a
parlé bien sûr personne n'a envie de
perdre sa place et les enveloppes qui
vont avec
être député de la france insoumise c'est
aussi se battre contre la loi travail on
parlait de sécurité la sécurité c'est la
violence des pauvres c'est la violence
que les salariés subissent dans leur
entreprise
c'est la violence que les retraités
subissent assez la violence que les
adolescents subissent quand ils trouvent
pas de travail qui n'ont pas d'écoles
pas de stage
c'est cette violence là dont on va dont
on va parler avec la france est soumise
au parlement
merci merci
michaud michel crouzet y aurait 34
seconde émission le président doit
appliquer son programme
il a su rassembler la majorité des
français c'est incontestable été élu
démocratiquement
c'est pourquoi je me dis je m'engage à
défendre les intérêts des citoyens de la
3e circonscription de l'yonne notre
territoire un très fort potentiel qui ne
demande qu'à être développé
je m'y engage ils enfin temps de faire
de la politique autrement pas pour un
parti ou un syndicat mais pour l'intérêt
de tous voté pour la république en
marche
votez pour moi votre nouvelle députée
merci beaucoup merci à tous les 6 à la
fin de cette émission
bonne journée